im berliner bezirk spandau werden die
schulen nicht mehr fünf mal die woche
gereinigt sondern nur noch vier mal um
geld zu sparen auf diese idee ist man im
bezirksamt aber nicht alleine gekommen
für diesen völlig banalen vorschlag hat
das amt eine unternehmensberatung
eingeschaltet und die stadt berlin zahlt
den beratern hier für satte 680.000 euro
honorar bekloppt essen hora es kann
nicht wahr sein so viel geld wird
verschwendet einfach eine schweinerei
wenig steigen die leute da reinstecken
handy mich darüber gefreut wenn ich den
vorschlag gemacht hätte die hätte ich
auch gerne genommen die 680 nur für
einen vorschlag gerne der bezirk spandau
will 2018 bei der schul reinigung sparen
und künftig weniger als die bisherigen
4,5 millionen euro für eine putzfirma
zahlen dafür beauftragt das bezirksamt
eine unternehmensberatung das
vereinbarte erfolgshonorar 45 prozent
der eingesparten summe in der
unternehmensberatung steckt man die
köpfe zusammen und denkt angestrengt
nach schließlich hat man die lösung putz
doch statt an fünf nur noch an vier
tagen für diese schlichte idee stellen
die berater 680.000 euro in rechnung und
man glaubt es kaum die spandauer
verwaltung zahlt postwendend für die
präsidentin des berliner rechnungshofes
eine riesige verschwendung der bezirk
hat ein völlig überholtes erfolgshonorar
dafür gezahlt dass zukünftig weniger in
den schulen in spandau gereinigt wird an
vier statt wie bisher an fünf tagen zu
reinigen
das entspricht der bisherigen die norm
darauf hätte der bezirk wirklich selber
kommen müssen mit anderen worten um auf
diese idee zu kommen hätten die
spandauer beamten einfach in die
geltenden richtlinien gucken müssen
trotzdem verteidigt der
bezirksbürgermeister den abenteuerlichen
deal schriftlich heißt es die von der
beauftragten firma unterbreiteten
vorschläge zur kürzung der
reinigungsleistung waren dahingehend
plausibel dass die vorgeschlagenen
kürzungen zu keinerlei qualitätsverlust
führen
würden darauf ist das bezirksamt
richtigerweise eingegangen
richtig und plausibel finden die
spandauer das gar nicht der
verschwendung sagt wir müssen ja dafür
arbeiten anderer auch das sind waren
sind wir sagt ihr bescheißen uns von
oben bis unten bereinigt müsste täglich
während im spandauer zahlt man für eine
überflüssige dienstleistung einen haufen
geld dafür wird in den schulen weniger
geputzt 1 in hradil im ach so armen
berlin